really honored my friend in my recent
coworker Eli Wallach to ask me to say a
few words before he's presented with
this long long time coming
honorary Oscar for amazing work done in
the film industry for over
three-quarters of a century of acting
after I was asked by his daughter
Catherine here and immediately saying
yes I put down the phone we walked in
this is true we walked in the living
room my wife and I we turned on the TV
and just starting and honestly right
after I said yeah just starting on that
on the on the TV was babydome and and we
all you know in this day and age it's
instant gratification so I went right to
the internet to find out how old Eli was
in baby doll and found out that he was
41 years old in his first film just a
year younger than I am now
now since that time now that was an 18
no no that was since that time there's
been a hundred and sixty-four
performances there's been 26
performances just on Broadway and
there's probably been hundreds of
performances and other types of theater
regional and off-broadway 70 some odd
years of performing and still going
strong at 95 years old next week
you